Trascrizione:
Mi sono accorto che la gente
non è perfettamente in asse.
Sono tutti un po' traballanti,
tutta l'umanità che dondola,
sbanda, slitta,
cerca di stare in piedi in qualsiasi modo.
Beh, riuscire a mantenersi in equilibrio
su un terreno instabile e insicuro
non è cosa facile;
ma dopo un po', ce la si fa.
Certo, non si può pretendere
che uno, concentrato com'è
per stare in piedi,
possa occuparsi degli altri, del mondo,
insomma, possa pensare: no.
Ma a parte questo, la gente
non ci fa neanche molto caso.
Ma sì, l'uomo si abitua a tutto:
ognuno c'ha il suo traballio,
chi a destra, chi a sinistra.
Basta non cercare punti fermi,
che tanto non ci sono.